[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
congo dit le lot à les amis walid a
ouvre en belgique le 11 mars alors
grande annonce ma mère a glissé des
golden ticket est dans certaines de vos
commandes les gagnants se verront offrir
des billets pour ce spectacle et
peut-être même des massages maman j'ai
fait ce que tu m'as demandé voilà c'est
du lourd
en
tout cas il ya une certitude qui
viennent c'est que le real madrid il
vous veulent encore plus ce soir qu
avant le match l'aïe a pas de doute
possible assure
alors demandé non mais là moi je me suis
fait dribbler rg pas eu la réponse à ma
question est ce que ça peut peser dans
la décision ouais je crois qu'il a dit
ouais on joue quoi on pèse pas une
décision sur un match mais c'est sûr que
si vous voulez que je vous réponde que
je savais que je vais dans une grande
équipe j'ai pas attendu de jeu le real
madrid un soir de février pour savoir
que je nomme des meilleures équipes du
monde
waouh
hu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et celui-là c'est l'endométriose
nous allons vous accompagner à l'école à
l'université aux sports au travail tous
le même jour j'espère que tu conduis
vite c'est quoi ta voiture c'est
l'endométriose et si quoi l'endométriose
c'est une meuf maladie qui touche plus
de 2 millions par mois qui touche plus
de deux millions de françaises n'importe
quel français de france ait connu je
suis considéré comme connus ou un non
ouf
merci
de rien
[Musique]
les patrons
elop
[Musique]
oh
à